back when I was young I'd watch things
like King Kong's dioramas all of us of
stop-motion animations and things like
that but I didn't really know what was
going into them at the time
so as I start watching more films I like
the gaudy aspects of them so I wanted to
mix up realistic prosthetics and I
didn't really know how to do that so I
went to art school and while I was there
as researching they're all different
movies that I like the monsters in and I
did the Dick Smith 3d makeup basic
course well as that art school and that
taught you had to do molds and how to
sculptress a fix and then I was
networking with myself portfolio and
that way I got work experience with
Kristine blundell on Burke and Hare and
after that I was looking to move into
prosthetics and I started on Dark
Shadows with tool Hollow and Christian
mallet I was a trainee there so I got to
work in the workshop and help apply some
of the werewolf makeup since it so and
it was nice it when it came to fruition
because I was getting to meat beef
answers when I was looking at the
different artists that I liked I did my
art degree on em my dissertation on the
zombie makeups of Tom Savini for the
George Romero films and how are they
compared to the CGI versions and as I
got more and more into it I was looking
at people like mark Cooley who's doing
very realistic prosthetics and so that
interests me greatly because you saw how
someone was transformed in one person to
someone looked completely different but
still believable I worked with Barry
when I was still a trainee back on Dark
Shadows and he was sculpting and I've
always kept in touch them afterwards and
as I've gone off to do other things and
he asked me back last summer to go off
to New York with him and John to do a
life cast a full-body cast so that was
the first time I'd worked and since
which was several years later and I also
came on season six to do the children of
forest makeups for Game of Thrones which
was full body makeup
that was the first time I'd work for
them after that since then after being
on set I came to work in the silicon
department and which meant I could work
on the pre-production and shooting which
was great so these are hand molds off
one of our body moves so these have been
life cast and molded from someone's
actual hands for these specifically you
have armature wire inside so this is lip
drone to give it strength so that the
arm doesn't just flop for the silicon
and what we do is we suspend the
armature with fish fishing line right
through it and then we mix up a color
for the silicon so we try to find a
color that we want it can either be of
dead tones or if it's going on to a body
that supposed to be someone who's
recently alive a little bit more warm
and then we pour up the autumn solids
within the void there and once that
comes out the edges get seamed and
trimmed and then they start to art
finish them in the painting department I
think the most challenging and enjoyable
work projects have worked on has been
Game of Thrones because there's such a
variety of the things I've done for it
and from the application onset to the
making of silicon pieces and a such a
variety within the pieces we have to
make from realistic burns to the White
Walkers silicon something has to be
completely transparent like glass so
there's a lot of processes I have to go
into to make something like that there's
different chemicals that are different
degrees of transparency so it's doing
lots of different tests to find that
which one is the most appropriate for
that that prosthetic and then it's
combining that with the general
processes to make a final piece you're
always learning I think even people who
are doing it for many years because the
chemicals can change so dramatically
they're still continuing to learn to me
personally I'm learning on every job
which is great and what's nice about
freelance is you get to move from the
different companies and you can learn
from one person something you've never
seen before and you begin to start
getting better at the thing you're doing
by allowing yourself to do it in a
slightly different way people who are
genuinely creative thrive within it and
you don't have to be an expert in Italy
at all the different areas you can learn
that as you go along as long as you're
patient and you practice so and just
being a good person to be around and fun
in the workshop is always a great help
so that's the people that you want to
work with the ones that make even the
worst days they're the best ones that
the type of people that get on really
well within prosthetics even if you're
not initially as long as you sort of
take notes and you're willing to learn
the processes you do become technical
and retained most people start and
they've never done things like
fiberglassing or so looking running
before so it's something that can be
picked up and learned over time but you
do get lost and different processes
under your belt by the time you're a
couple years in because lots of people
do move about quite a lot within the
department my best advice would be just
practice at home initially do things
like drawing and just try sure what
you're interested in and then when you
approach different bosses you can do
well I'm not great yet but how would you
how would you improve this makeup and
just sure you enthusiasm that way when
you get into the workshop just be happy
to be around other people looking at
what they're doing and you can learn off
them quite easily rather than wanting to
jump ahead and be a sculptor as soon as
you start because you learn that over
time it's just getting that experience
and building upon it it's important I
think there's quite an impression it's
going to be a quick glamorous life on
say all the time and I didn't have that
expectation I know a lot of people do
the only thing I'd say otherwise is I
wish I knew I should have learnt to
drive them seventeen for ticket until I
was in my 20s and because a lot of the
film studios are quite far out or the
workshops are quite far out I would
spend several hours a day trainer and go
by public transport and that's just a
nightmare
[Music]
[Music]